- Every spring in rurr--
Every spring in rurr--
(laughs)
It's hard to say!
Every spring in rural Vermont
the sound of sap
dripping into galvanized metal buckets
signal the beginning of
the traditional season
for gathering maple syrup.
Or maybe we have no error.
So, what's the real subject here?
Every spring in rurr--
(laughs)
I can't say that!
Every spring in rural Vermont
the sound of sap dripping
into galvanized metal buckets.
So this is the subject here,
"the sound of sap dripping
"into galvanized metal buckets."
Now, is that singular or plural?
We're talking about the sound,
we're talking about a
sound, the sound here,
we're not talking about the sounds!
So this right over here,
this right over here,
is a singular subject.
Now, what do they do with the verb?
Well the verb right over here,
they have the plural form
of the verb "signal."
If we had the sounds,
we could say, "the sounds signal
"the beginning of the traditional season,"
but we have only,
we only have one sound,
we have the sound.
The sound, we need--
it's a singular subject,
we need a singular verb.
So we need "signals" right over here,
so the error is in Part C.